in florence alabama
and i know that's damn good and well not
where the you were supposed to be
it's just two and a half hours down the
road okay then what the [ __ ] are you
doing two and a half hours away from
your community service bar
helping people everybody but like the
people you need to be helping
i do help you
how have you been helping us june for
the last three and a half years we've
been taking care of alana we've been
providing groceries we've been paying
the bills
what have you done for us we've been
doing it all i get the girls need me but
they've got to understand that you know
i have to help others in my own recovery
would you prefer me to use
and not be a part of y'all's life at all
or help the next person prevent them
from their family going through the same
things that i put
my own family through are you ever going
to tell jessica that she needs to stop
looking for places
i didn't say that i might not move in
with jessica
well the way you're acting and your
actions are proven very much different
you're just out running around with your
clothes basket
[Music]
well now i've got a suitcase matter of
fact ain't even your suitcase it's mine
you know what i just wish honestly that
you would just get your head out of your
ass and just tell the truth because
nobody gives a
so i guess you can just leave your two
kids here and i'll continue to take care
of them
she pisses me off
no
she's worried about taking care of
everybody else except for the people
that really need her help and that's us